[Music]
thank you thank you thank you this is uh
what I look like yeah yeah my lady she
said to me recently she goes I want to
talk about our sexual fantasies I was
like you might want to go first she goes
well sometimes I fantasize about you
being a little bit more muscular
sometimes I fantasize about you being a
little less of a judgmental
can't be too mad at her kid okay if
you're too mad at my top 26 fantasies
don't even involve her number 13 doesn't
involve me for God's sakes you think
this is what I wanted to look like you
think this what I was going for just
bones wrapped in pale skin
it's disgusting every time I take off my
shirt I feel like I should apologize to
people that are actually sick can't even
wear watches some of you guys got nice
watches on it can't wear watches they
slide down to my bicep hey what time is
it just not tough you know I'm not manly
I don't do anything manly I'm from
Minnesota and I don't even hunt although
I do think we should stop hunting I
think we should stop hunting deer I
think if we stopped hunting deer that
stops suicide-bombing our cars
[Music]
that's what's happening folks they're
not blinded by the lights and then
they're running for your car that
doesn't even make any sense stop saying
that know the older bucks are taking all
the young uneducated poor dear and
they're turning them into
fundamentalists that's what's happening
promises of eternal afterlife for the
hot whitetail they can handle
I gotta get tough I gotta get tough for
him and I have to take care of a family
soon I'm gonna have to protect a family
maybe my lady she just stopped taking
her birth control yeah she thinks that
since she stopped taking her birth
control it's cause you to gain weight I
think it's all the cake I've been hiding
her pill in she loves just there I don't
want to be a dad man I don't want to be
a dad I want to be a stepdad that's what
I really want to be I want to be a
stepdad that's where it's at right kid
turns out okay like yeah I hope to raise
them peace of complete you're like
good I don't like a meson my kid talked
to his dad already can't be having kids
I can't even take care of myself a
scheduled two dentist appointment last
week for the first time in six years
yeah so last week i flossed my teeth for
the first time in six years yeah when I
woke up in the bathroom floor after
passing out from a loss of blood I
realized that I missed my dentist
appointment
can't be having kids man i got nothing i
got nothing not liked you guys I don't
have it all figured out you know I got
credit card debt my friends Netflix
password those are the two things that I
have it's not even his password it's
like his cousins or whatever we're all
using like one of 10 Netflix logins
there's like 10 of them out there if you
have your own Netflix login you're in
the Illuminati that's what that means
yeah you're going to Eyes Wide Shut
parties I just missed what I was
supposed to be folks you know I mean I
missed what I should have been I know it
I would have been good at I know what I
should have been I should have been a
Civil War general that's what I should
have been I'm serious I would have been
the greatest Civil War general of all
time I went to one every single battle
I just would have gone it's my troops
before every battle like a palace this
time but side behind some stuff
used to fight like idiots in the civil
lawyers getting big lines like 50 feet
apart and shoot each other in the face
for like four straight days and then
they would March the next battle blowing
into trumpets and pounding on drums
because they hated surprises in the
Civil War they hated them hey so I make
sure you know we're coming
yes case you don't got your cannons
ready no I just aim them straight well
walk right in
[Applause]
you